ยินดีต้อนรับกลับสู่ความเข้าใจเรื่องข้อมูลควอนตัมและการคำนวณ ฉันชื่อ John Watrous และเป็นผู้อำนวยการฝ่ายเทคนิคด้านการศึกษาที่ IBM Quantum
นี่คือบทเรียนที่ 13 ของซีรีส์นี้ และเป็นบทเรียนแรกในหน่วยที่สี่และหน่วยสุดท้าย ซึ่งเป็นเรื่องของข้อผิดพลาดควอนตัม
การแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดควอนตัม การคำนวณควอนตัมมีศักยภาพที่จะทำให้สามารถหาทางแก้ปัญหาที่มีประสิทธิภาพสำหรับงานการคำนวณที่
ยังไม่มีอัลกอริทึมแบบคลาสสิกที่มีประสิทธิภาพ และอาจจะไม่มีเลยด้วยซ้ำ แต่มีความท้าทายที่สำคัญมากที่
จะต้องก้าวผ่านไปให้ได้ หากเราต้องการนำการคำนวณควอนตัมขนาดใหญ่มาใช้งานตามที่เราหวังว่าจะเป็นไปได้ในสักวันหนึ่ง
หัวใจของปัญหาคือข้อมูลควอนตัมนั้นเปราะบางมาก แค่มองดูมันก็ทำให้เสียหายได้เลย
ดังนั้นเพื่อให้ทำงานได้ถูกต้อง คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมต้องแยกข้อมูลควอนตัมที่เก็บไว้
ออกจากสภาพแวดล้อมรอบข้างอย่างเข้มงวดมาก แต่ในขณะเดียวกันคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเองก็ต้องให้เรา
ควบคุมข้อมูลควอนตัมนี้ได้อย่างแม่นยำมาก ซึ่งรวมถึงการเริ่มต้นที่เหมาะสม การทำงานแบบ unitary ที่แม่นยำและเชื่อถือได้
และแน่นอนรวมถึงความสามารถในการวัดผลด้วย เพื่อให้เราได้รับผลลัพธ์ของ
การคำนวณจริงๆ มีความขัดแย้งชัดเจนระหว่างข้อกำหนดเหล่านี้ และในช่วงต้นของการคำนวณควอนตัมมีบางคนมองว่าความเปราะบาง
ของข้อมูลควอนตัมและความอ่อนแอต่อทั้งความไม่แม่นยำและสัญญาณรบกวนจากสิ่งแวดล้อมจะทำให้
การคำนวณควอนตัมเป็นไปไม่ได้ในที่สุด ทุกวันนี้แทบไม่มีใครสงสัยเลยว่าการสร้างคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมที่แม่นยำและเชื่อถือได้
ขนาดใหญ่นั้นเป็นความท้าทายมหาศาล แต่เรามีเครื่องมือสำคัญที่ช่วยเราในความพยายามนี้ ซึ่งทำให้คนส่วนใหญ่
ที่รู้จักสาขานี้ดีมีความหวังว่าการคำนวณควอนตัมขนาดใหญ่จะกลายเป็นความจริงในสักวัน และเครื่องมือนั้นก็คือการแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดควอนตัม
ในบทเรียนสี่บทถัดไปเราจะพูดถึงการแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดควอนตัม โดยเน้นที่
หลักพื้นฐาน ในบทเรียนนี้เราจะมาทำความรู้จักกับการแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดควอนตัมครั้งแรก รวมถึงหนึ่งในโค้ดแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดควอนตัมที่ค้นพบเป็นอันดับแรกๆ
นั่นคือ 9 qubit Shore code และเราจะพูดถึงแนวคิดพื้นฐานอีกอย่างในการแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดควอนตัม
ซึ่งรู้จักกันในชื่อ discretization of errors ในบทเรียนถัดไปของหน่วยนี้เราจะเห็นการสร้างโค้ดแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดควอนตัมที่ซับซ้อนและดีกว่า
รวมถึงพูดถึงปัญหาของการคำนวณควอนตัมบนข้อมูลควอนตัมที่เข้ารหัสไว้ โดยใช้
ส่วนประกอบการคำนวณที่ไม่สมบูรณ์แบบและมีโอกาสเกิดข้อผิดพลาด นี่คือภาพรวมของ
บทเรียน เราจะเริ่มต้นด้วยการพูดถึง classical repetition codes ซึ่งอาจเป็นประเภท
ที่ง่ายและพื้นฐานที่สุดของ classical error correcting code classical repetition codes ไม่ถือเป็นโค้ดที่ดีโดย
มาตรฐานของทฤษฎีการเข้ารหัสแบบคลาสสิก อย่างน้อยก็เมื่อใช้คนเดียว แต่ก็โอเคในที่นี้เราเน้นความเรียบง่าย และโดยเฉพาะ
เราจะดู classical error correcting code ที่เรียบง่ายที่สุดเท่าที่จะนึกออก แล้วใช้เป็นฐานสำหรับตัวอย่างง่ายๆ
ของ quantum error correcting code ตัวอย่างนั้นคือ 9 qubit Shore code ซึ่งเราจะพูดถึงอย่างละเอียด
รวมถึงการอธิบายตัวโค้ดเอง รวมถึงขั้นตอนการเข้ารหัส qubit โดยใช้โค้ดนี้ การตรวจจับข้อผิดพลาดบน qubit ที่เข้ารหัสแล้ว และ
การแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดเหล่านั้น และในส่วนที่สามของบทเรียนเราจะพูดถึง discretization of errors ซึ่งช่วยให้เราคิดเกี่ยวกับข้อผิดพลาดที่เกิดขึ้นกับ
qubit ซึ่งในหลักการแล้วมีความต่อเนื่องของความเป็นไปได้ในรูปแบบที่ไม่ต่อเนื่อง โดยพื้นฐานแล้วลดข้อผิดพลาดลงเป็น
สิ่งที่เรียกว่า bit flip และ phase flip ก่อนที่เราจะเข้าสู่รายละเอียดทางเทคนิคของการแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดควอนตัม
ก็คุ้มค่าที่จะใช้เวลาสักครู่พิจารณาความจำเป็นของการแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดควอนตัมรวมถึง classical error
correction ดังที่ฉันได้แนะนำตอนต้นบทเรียน คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมมีความเสี่ยงต่อข้อผิดพลาดสูงมากเนื่องจาก
ความเปราะบางของข้อมูลควอนตัม โดยเฉพาะการมีปฏิสัมพันธ์ที่ไม่ต้องการกับสิ่งแวดล้อม หรือใน
คำพูดอื่น โลกที่เหลืออยู่นั้น สามารถรบกวนข้อมูลควอนตัมได้ การมีปฏิสัมพันธ์ที่ไม่ต้องการเหล่านี้อาจทำให้เกิด decoherence โดยที่ข้อมูล
จะรั่วไหลเข้าสู่สิ่งแวดล้อม ทำให้ข้อมูลที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเก็บไว้มีพฤติกรรมที่เป็นคลาสสิกมากขึ้น
นอกจากนี้ยังสำคัญมากที่เราต้องรับรู้ว่าการดำเนินการควอนตัมสามารถทำได้ด้วยความแม่นยำที่จำกัดเท่านั้น
ตัวอย่างเช่น เราอาจต้องการทำ quantum gate เฉพาะบน qubit แต่เนื่องจากอุปกรณ์จริงนั้น
ไม่มีความสมบูรณ์แบบ สิ่งที่เรานำมาใช้จริงอาจเป็นแค่ค่าประมาณของ gate นั้น ซึ่งอาจไม่ใช่ปัญหาใหญ่สำหรับ
gate เดียว แต่ถ้าเจตนาของเราคือการทำ quantum gate หลายพัน หรือหลายล้านครั้ง ความไม่แม่นยำเล็กน้อยเหล่านี้จะ
เริ่มสะสม และเมื่อการคำนวณเสร็จสิ้น เราอาจได้สถานะที่แตกต่างจากที่คาดไว้มาก
นี่จึงเป็นแหล่งที่มาของข้อผิดพลาดที่ค่อนข้างแตกต่าง แต่แน่นอนว่าเป็นสิ่งที่เราไม่อาจ
มองข้ามได้ ผู้คนศึกษา classical error correcting codes มาเกือบหนึ่งศตวรรษ และโค้ดเหล่านี้มีการประยุกต์ใช้งานมากมายรวมถึง
การส่งและจัดเก็บข้อมูล แต่เนื่องจากส่วนประกอบการคำนวณแบบคลาสสิกมีความน่าเชื่อถือสูงมาก เราจึงไม่จำเป็นต้อง
ใช้ error correction ในการสร้างคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิก ตอนนี้อาจเป็นไปได้ว่า error correction ไม่จำเป็น
สำหรับการสร้างคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมขนาดใหญ่ที่เชื่อถือได้เลยก็ได้ ตัวอย่างเช่น แนวคิดหลักของ topological quantum
computing คือ อาจเป็นไปได้ที่จะสร้างระบบควอนตัมที่แข็งแกร่งซึ่งป้องกันสัญญาณรบกวนโดยธรรมชาติเนื่องจาก
คุณสมบัติทางโทโพโลยีของระบบ แต่เราไม่รู้ว่าสิ่งนี้จะเป็นไปได้หรือไม่ และเชื่อกันอย่างกว้างขวางว่า
error correction จะน่าจะจำเป็นในรูปแบบใดรูปแบบหนึ่งสำหรับการคำนวณควอนตัมขนาดใหญ่ ตอนนี้เราจะพูดถึง classical
repetition codes ซึ่งเป็นพื้นฐานสำหรับ quantum error correcting code แรกของเรา คือ 9 qubit Shore code ซึ่ง
เราจะเห็นในไม่ช้า repetition codes เป็นตัวอย่างพื้นฐานมากของ error correcting codes
แนวคิดคือเราสามารถป้องกันบิตจากข้อผิดพลาดได้โดยการทำซ้ำแต่ละบิตหลายครั้ง โดยเฉพาะอย่างยิ่งลองดู
three-bit repetition code นี่เราเข้ารหัสหนึ่งบิตเป็นสามบิตโดยเพียงแค่ทำซ้ำบิตสามครั้ง ดังนั้น
ศูนย์ถูกเข้ารหัสเป็น 000 และหนึ่งถูกเข้ารหัสเป็น 111 แน่นอนว่าถ้าไม่มีอะไรผิดพลาด เรา
สามารถแยกแยะสองความเป็นไปได้ได้ง่ายๆ แต่ถ้าเกิดข้อผิดพลาดและบิตหนึ่งพลิก เช่น
ศูนย์เปลี่ยนเป็นหนึ่ง หรือหนึ่งเปลี่ยนเป็นศูนย์ เราก็ยังสามารถหาได้ว่าบิตต้นฉบับคืออะไร
โดยดูว่าค่าไบนารีไหนปรากฏขึ้นสองครั้ง หรืออีกทางหนึ่งเราสามารถถอดรหัสโดยคำนวณค่า majority
หรืออีกนัยหนึ่งค่าไบนารีที่ปรากฏบ่อยที่สุด และไม่ยากที่จะเห็นว่า
ถ้าเรามีข้อผิดพลาด bit flip มากที่สุดหนึ่งครั้ง การถอดรหัสจะถูกต้อง แน่นอนว่าถ้าสองบิตพลิกหรือ
สามบิตพลิก มันก็จะไม่ทำงาน และเราจะได้ค่าที่ผิดเมื่อถอดรหัส และนั่นเป็นคุณสมบัติทั่วไป
ที่ทุก error correcting code มี คุณอาจสามารถแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดบางอย่างได้ แต่คุณไม่มีทางแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดทุกอย่างได้ และในท้ายที่สุดมันเป็นเรื่องของ
การลดโอกาสของข้อผิดพลาด ไม่ใช่รับประกันความถูกต้อง ซึ่งโดยทั่วไปเป็นไปไม่ได้
เป็นไปได้ตัวอย่างของสถานการณ์ที่เราสามารถลดโอกาสทำผิดพลาดได้ สมมติว่า
เป้าหมายของเราคือส่งบิตเดียวให้ผู้รับที่สมมุติขึ้น และเพื่อทำสิ่งนี้เราสามารถส่งบิตผ่าน
สิ่งที่เรียกว่า binary symmetric channel ซึ่งพลิกแต่ละบิตที่ส่งผ่านมันอย่างอิสระด้วยความน่าจะเป็น
P ดังนั้นด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 1 ลบ P ผู้รับจะได้บิตที่เราตั้งใจส่ง แต่ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น P
บิตจะพลิกและผู้รับจะได้ค่าตรงข้ามกับสิ่งที่เราส่ง ดังนั้นถ้าเราไม่ใช้ repetition
code แต่เพียงส่งบิตที่คิดไว้ผ่าน channel ผู้รับจะได้บิตที่ผิดด้วยความน่าจะเป็น
P ในทางกลับกัน ถ้าเราเข้ารหัสบิตที่ต้องการส่งโดยใช้ three-bit repetition code ก่อนแล้ว
ส่งแต่ละบิตของการเข้ารหัสผ่าน channel แล้วแต่ละบิตก็จะพลิกด้วยความน่าจะเป็น P ดังนั้น
โอกาสที่บิตจะพลิกนั้นมีมากขึ้นเพราะตอนนี้มีสามบิตที่อาจพลิกได้แทนที่จะเป็นหนึ่ง
แต่ถ้าบิตพลิกไม่เกินหนึ่งบิต ผู้รับจะสามารถถอดรหัสได้ถูกต้อง ดังนั้นเราจะเกิดข้อผิดพลาดหลังจาก
ถอดรหัสก็ต่อเมื่อมีสองบิตหรือมากกว่าพลิกระหว่างการส่ง และไม่ยากนักที่จะคำนวณว่าสิ่งนี้เกิดขึ้นด้วยความน่าจะเป็น
3 คูณ P กำลังสอง ลบ 2 คูณ P กำลังสาม สำหรับค่า P ที่เล็กกว่า 1 หาร 12
สิ่งนี้ทำให้ความน่าจะเป็นที่ผู้รับจะได้บิตที่ผิดลดลง ยังคงมีโอกาสเกิดข้อผิดพลาดในกรณีนี้ แต่
โค้ดช่วยลดความเป็นไปได้ และถ้าต้องการลดโอกาสลงอีก ก็สามารถทำได้โดยใช้
โค้ดอื่น รวมถึงแต่ไม่จำกัดแค่การใช้ repetition code ที่บิตที่เข้ารหัสถูกทำซ้ำ
มากกว่าสามครั้ง สำหรับค่า P ที่มากกว่า 1 หาร 12 โดยวิธี โค้ดจริงๆ แล้วทำให้
สิ่งต่างๆ แย่ลงในแง่ที่ว่ามันเพิ่มความน่าจะเป็นที่ผู้รับจะได้บิตที่ผิด ดังนั้นเราคงไม่ใช้โค้ดนี้ในสถานการณ์นั้น
three-bit repetition code เป็น classical error correcting code แต่เราสามารถพิจารณาสิ่งที่จะเกิดขึ้นถ้าเรา
ลองใช้มันเพื่อป้องกัน qubit จากข้อผิดพลาด มันไม่ใช่ quantum error correcting code ที่ดีนักอย่างที่เราจะเห็น
มันสามารถแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดบางอย่างได้ แต่ทำให้ข้อผิดพลาดอื่นน่าจะเป็นมากขึ้น อย่างไรก็ตามมันเป็นก้าวแรกสู่ shore
code ดังนั้นลองดูว่ามันทำงานยังไงสำหรับ qubit ก่อนอื่นให้ชัดเจนเมื่อเราพูดถึง 3-bit repetition code ที่ใช้
สำหรับ qubit สิ่งที่เราคิดถึงคือการเข้ารหัส qubit ดังที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ ที่ Alpha 0 บวก beta 1 ถูก
เข้ารหัสเป็น Alpha 000 บวก beta 111 หรืออีกนัยหนึ่ง standard basis state
ถูกทำซ้ำสามครั้ง สังเกตโดยเฉพาะว่านี่ไม่เหมือนกับการทำซ้ำ quantum state สามครั้งในแบบที่ quantum
state S ถูกเข้ารหัสเป็น S tensor S tensor S ซึ่งไม่ใช่การเข้ารหัสที่เราจะสามารถ
นำมาใช้กับ quantum state S ที่ไม่รู้จักโดย no cloning theorem การเข้ารหัสที่เราพูดถึง
ในทางกลับกันนำมาใช้ได้อย่างง่ายดาย นี่คือ quantum circuit ง่ายๆ ที่ทำมันโดยใช้ qubit workspace ที่เริ่มต้นแล้วสองตัวและ
controlled NOT gate สองตัว ตอนนี้สมมติว่ามีข้อผิดพลาดเกิดขึ้นหลังจากการเข้ารหัส
เสร็จสิ้น โดยเฉพาะสมมติว่าการดำเนินการ Pauli X หรืออีกนัยหนึ่ง bit flip เกิดขึ้นบน
qubit ตัวหนึ่ง และในรูปนี้คือ qubit ตัวกลาง แน่นอนว่านี่ไม่ใช่ข้อผิดพลาดประเภทเดียวที่อาจเกิดขึ้น และคุณอาจ
คัดค้านแนวคิดที่ว่าข้อผิดพลาดมีรูปแบบของ unitary operation ที่สมบูรณ์แบบนี้ แต่เราจะกลับมาที่เรื่องนี้ในภายหลังในบทเรียน และตอนนี้เรา
เพียงแค่คิดว่ามันเป็นตัวอย่าง นี่คือสถานะผลลัพธ์ มันเหมือนกับการเข้ารหัสต้นฉบับ ยกเว้น
บิตกลางในแต่ละ ket ถูกพลิก แน่นอนว่าเราเห็นสิ่งนี้ได้จากการแสดงออกทางคณิตศาสตร์ของสถานะ
แต่สมมติว่าเรามีแค่สาม qubit และเราสงสัยว่า bit flip อาจเกิดขึ้น แต่เราไม่รู้ว่า qubit ตัวไหนอาจได้รับ
ผลกระทบ วิธีหนึ่งที่จะหาว่า bit flip เกิดขึ้นหรือไม่คือการวัด standard basis แล้วดูผลลัพธ์ ในกรณีนี้เราจะเห็น
0 หนึ่ง 0 หรือ 1 หนึ่ง ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นที่ขึ้นอยู่กับ Alpha และ beta และในทั้งสองกรณีข้อสรุปของเรา
คือบิตกลางพลิก แต่น่าเสียดายที่สิ่งนั้นทำลาย quantum state ต้นฉบับ และสถานะนี้
อาจมีค่ามากสำหรับเรา หลังจากทั้งหมดจุดประสงค์ทั้งหมดคือการปกป้อง quantum state นี้ ดังนั้นนี่ไม่ใช่
ทางเลือกที่ดี สิ่งที่เราทำได้แทนคือใช้ quantum circuit ที่แสดงที่นี่บนหน้าจอ ที่เราป้อนสถานะที่เข้ารหัส
เข้าสู่สาม qubit บนสุด โดยพื้นฐานแล้ว circuit ทำอะไรคือคำนวณ parity ของ standard
basis states สำหรับสอง qubit บนสุด รวมถึงสอง qubit ล่างสุดของการเข้ารหัส และสิ่งนี้จะเปิดเผย
ตำแหน่งของ bit flip โดยเฉพาะในกรณีนี้เราจะได้ผลลัพธ์ 1 สำหรับการตรวจสอบ parity ทั้งสองนี้ และจาก
ข้อมูลนั้นเราสรุปได้ว่าบิตกลางแตกต่างจากอีกสองบิต นั่นคือบิตที่
พลิกชัดเจนและสำคัญมากที่สิ่งนี้ไม่ทำให้สถานะ collapse ดังนั้นตอนนี้เรามีโอกาสพยายามแก้ไข bit
flip นี้ เพื่อที่ในที่สุดเราอาจสามารถถอดรหัสและได้สถานะต้นฉบับกลับมา เราจะกลับมาที่การแก้ไข
ในอีกสักครู่ แต่ก่อนอื่นลองพิจารณาความเป็นไปได้อื่นสำหรับข้อผิดพลาด bit flip ถ้าข้อผิดพลาด bit flip
เกิดขึ้นที่ qubit ล่างหรือซ้าย เราจะได้ผลลัพธ์ 1 ศูนย์ อ่านจากล่างขึ้นบน และอีกครั้ง
สถานะจะไม่เปลี่ยนแปลง และถ้า bit flip เกิดขึ้นที่ qubit บน ผลลัพธ์จะเป็น
01 และอีกครั้งสถานะไม่เปลี่ยนแปลง และโดยวิธีถ้าไม่มี
bit flip เลย ผลการวัดคือ 0 0 และอีกครั้งสถานะออกมาไม่เปลี่ยนแปลง
มาสรุปทั้งหมดนี้ในรูปแบบตาราง ที่เราแสดงแต่ละสถานะที่เป็นไปได้ที่เราได้จากข้อผิดพลาด bit flip ไม่เกินหนึ่งครั้ง ผลการวัด
ที่เราเรียกว่า syndrome ในบริบทของ error correction และการแก้ไขที่เราต้องทำเพื่อให้ได้ต้นฉบับ
การเข้ารหัสคืน ถ้าไม่มีข้อผิดพลาด syndrome คือ 0 0 และไม่จำเป็นต้องแก้ไข
สถานะ ถ้า qubit ล่างหรือซ้ายสุดมี bit flip ผลลัพธ์ syndrome คือ 1 0 และการแก้ไขที่เหมาะสม
คือการ apply X gate ที่ qubit ล่างหรือซ้ายสุด และอีกสองกรณีก็
คล้ายกัน ดังนั้นถ้าเรา apply การแก้ไขที่เหมาะสมตาม syndrome เราก็มั่นใจได้ว่าจะได้การเข้ารหัสต้นฉบับกลับมา
ในทั้งสี่กรณี อีกครั้งเราพิจารณาเฉพาะความเป็นไปได้ที่มี bit flip
ไม่เกินหนึ่งครั้ง สิ่งนี้จะไม่ทำงานถูกต้องถ้าสองหรือสามบิตพลิก และเรายังไม่ได้พิจารณา
ความเป็นไปได้ของข้อผิดพลาดอื่น ตอนนี้ลองพิจารณาข้อผิดพลาดประเภทต่าง ๆ ในระบบควอนตัม bit
flip errors ไม่ใช่ข้อผิดพลาดเดียวที่เราต้องกังวล ตัวอย่างเช่น เราต้องกังวลเกี่ยวกับ phase flip
errors หรือ phase flips สั้นๆ ด้วย ซึ่งอธิบายโดย Z gates หรือเทียบเท่า Pauli Z
operations น่าเสียดายที่ three-bit repetition code ล้มเหลวโดยสิ้นเชิงในการตรวจจับ phase flip ตัวอย่างเช่น สมมติว่าเรา
เข้ารหัส qubit โดยใช้ 3-bit repetition code เหมือนเดิม และมีข้อผิดพลาด phase flip เกิดขึ้นที่
qubit กลาง เราจะได้สถานะที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ ซึ่งก็คือการเข้ารหัสที่เราจะได้รับถ้า
phase flip เกิดขึ้นกับ qubit ต้นฉบับก่อนที่เราจะเข้ารหัส ดังนั้นถ้าเราทำ
circuit เดิมเพื่อตรวจจับข้อผิดพลาด เราจะได้ syndrome 0 0 ซึ่งบอกผิดว่าไม่มีข้อผิดพลาดเกิดขึ้น
ดังนั้น 3 bit repetition code ทำงานได้สำหรับ bit flip error ไม่เกินหนึ่งครั้ง แต่ล้มเหลวในการตรวจจับ phase flip errors ใน
ความจริงมันทำให้สิ่งต่างๆ แย่ลงในบางแง่ เพราะตอนนี้เรามี qubit มากขึ้นสามเท่าที่อาจเกิด phase flip
errors เราสังเกตว่า three-bit repetition code ไม่สนใจ phase flip errors โดยสิ้นเชิง ดังนั้นดูเหมือนจะ
ไม่มีประโยชน์มากในการจัดการกับข้อผิดพลาดประเภทนี้ แต่จริงๆ แล้วเราสามารถปรับแต่ง three-bit repetition code เพื่อให้มัน
ตรวจจับ phase flip errors ได้ และฉันจะอธิบายตอนนี้ว่าสิ่งนี้สามารถทำได้อย่างไร นี่คือ circuit ต้นฉบับสำหรับ
การเข้ารหัส qubit โดยใช้ 3-bit repetition code และวิธีที่เราจะแก้ไขมันนั้นเรียบง่ายมาก เพียงแค่ apply
Hadamard gate กับ qubit แต่ละตัวของการเข้ารหัส Hadamard gate แปลง zero state เป็น plus state และ one
state เป็น minus state ดังนั้นผลลัพธ์สุทธิคือเราได้สถานะที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ ที่ ket
Plus Plus plus และ ket minus minus minus เป็นสัญลักษณ์ย่อสำหรับ tensor ของสาม plus state หรือสาม minus
states ข้อผิดพลาด phase flip หรืออีกนัยหนึ่ง Z gate แปลง plus state เป็น minus state และ minus state เป็น
plus state ดังนั้นการเข้ารหัสนี้จะเป็นประโยชน์สำหรับการตรวจจับและแก้ไข phase flip errors และเพื่อทำสิ่งนั้นเราสามารถ
ปรับแต่ง error detection circuit จากก่อนดังต่อไปนี้ นี่คือ circuit จากก่อน และสิ่งที่เราจะทำคือ
เพียงแค่ใส่ Hadamard gates ทั้งที่ต้นทางและปลายทางดังที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ
แนวคิดนั้นเรียบง่ายมาก Hadamard gates สามตัวแรกแปลง plus และ minus states กลับเป็น zero และ one states
การตรวจสอบ parity เหมือนก่อนจะเกิดขึ้น แล้ว Hadamard gates ชั้นที่สองนำเรากลับสู่
การเข้ารหัสของเรา อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการคิดเกี่ยวกับเรื่องนี้คือเราเพียงแค่แปลง phase flip errors เป็น bit flip errors โดย conjugate โดย Hadamard
operations โดยวิธีเราสามารถลดความซับซ้อนของ circuit เล็กน้อย circuit นี้เทียบเท่ากันอย่างสมบูรณ์
และคุณสามารถตรวจสอบสิ่งนี้ด้วยตัวเองถ้าต้องการ ดังนั้นถ้าเราป้อน qubit ที่เข้ารหัสเข้าสู่ circuit นี้ สมมติ
ว่าไม่มีข้อผิดพลาด phase flip เราจะได้ syndrome 0 0 บ่งชี้ว่าไม่มี phase flip
errors และถ้าเรามี phase flip error ที่ qubit บน เช่น plus และ minus ขวาสุดก็จะสลับกัน
และนั่นทำให้เกิด error syndrome ที่แตกต่างออกไป 01 ซึ่งในกรณีนี้ระบุตำแหน่งของ phase flip เหมือน
ที่เราทำกับ bit flip และเราสามารถแก้ไขได้โดย apply Z gate กับ qubit บน และสถานการณ์
ก็คล้ายกันสำหรับ phase flip errors บน qubit อีกสองตัว ดังนั้นเราสามารถตรวจจับและ
แก้ไข phase flip error ได้ไม่เกินหนึ่งครั้งโดยใช้โค้ดนี้ แต่น่าเสียดายที่อย่างที่คุณอาจเดาแล้ว เราไม่สามารถ
แก้ไข bit flip errors ได้อีกต่อไป อย่างไรก็ตามไม่ได้สูญเสียทุกอย่าง เพราะเราสามารถรวมสองโค้ดเหล่านี้
เข้าด้วยกันเพื่อได้โค้ดที่สามารถแก้ไขทั้ง bit flip และ phase flip errors และจริงๆ แล้วมันจะสามารถ
แก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดใดๆ บน qubit เดียวได้ ถึงเวลาพูดถึง 9 qubit Shore code ซึ่งเป็น quantum
error correcting code ที่เราได้มาโดยการรวมสองโค้ดที่เพิ่งเห็น ซึ่งหมายถึง three bit
repetition code ที่ช่วยแก้ไข bit flip error เดียว และเวอร์ชันที่ดัดแปลงซึ่งช่วยแก้ไข phase flip
error เดียว ให้ชัดเจนขึ้น 9 qubit Shore code คือโค้ดที่เราได้โดยการ concatenate สองโค้ด ซึ่งหมายถึง
เราก่อนอื่น apply การเข้ารหัสหนึ่งที่เข้ารหัส qubit หนึ่งเป็นสาม จากนั้น apply การเข้ารหัสอื่นกับแต่ละตัวใน
สาม qubit แยกกัน ดังนั้นเราจะได้เก้า qubit ทั้งหมด เราสามารถแสดงสิ่งนี้ในรูปแบบ
circuit diagram ดังต่อไปนี้ ก่อนอื่นเราจะ apply เวอร์ชันที่ดัดแปลงของ 3-bit repetition code
ที่ตรวจจับ phase flip errors จากนั้นเราจะเข้ารหัส qubit ที่ได้แต่ละตัวอย่างอิสระโดยใช้
3-bit repetition code ต้นฉบับ ดังนั้นถ้าเราย่อ circuit นี้เล็กน้อยเพื่อให้มีที่ว่างมากขึ้น เราก็สามารถ
ระบุโค้ดในรูปแบบที่ต่างออกไปเล็กน้อยโดยอธิบายว่า standard basis states สองตัวสำหรับ qubit ต้นฉบับของเราถูก
เข้ารหัสอย่างไร และเมื่อเรารู้สิ่งนี้แล้ว เราสามารถกำหนดโดย linearity ว่า qubit state vector ที่ arbitrary ได้รับ
การเข้ารหัสอย่างไร ดังนั้นนั่นคือ 9 qubit Shore code และแนวคิดคือโค้ดตัวหนึ่งช่วยให้เราแก้ไข phase flip
errors และโค้ดอื่นช่วยให้เราแก้ไข bit flip errors และอย่างที่เราจะเห็น สิ่งนั้นจริงๆ แล้วหมายความว่าเราสามารถ
แก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดที่ arbitrary บน qubit เดียวได้ ตอนนี้มาดูว่าเราสามารถตรวจจับและแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดโดยใช้ 9 qubit
Shore code ได้อย่างไร เริ่มด้วย bit flip errors ซึ่งเรียกอีกอย่างว่า X errors นี่คือ circuit ที่ทำ
การเข้ารหัส และเพื่อให้พูดถึงได้ง่ายขึ้น เราจะคิดถึงเก้า qubit ที่เราได้จากโค้ดนี้ว่าถูก
จัดกลุ่มเป็นสาม blocks แต่ละ block มีสาม qubit โดยที่แต่ละ block แทนการเข้ารหัสที่เราได้จาก
ขั้นตอนการเข้ารหัสที่สอง ซึ่งคือ ordinary 3-bit repetition code ที่เรียกว่า inner code ใน
บริบทนี้ ในขณะที่ outer code คือโค้ดที่ใช้สำหรับขั้นตอนการเข้ารหัสแรก ซึ่งในกรณีนี้คือเวอร์ชันที่ดัดแปลง
ของ three-bit repetition code ที่ทำงานได้กับ phase flip errors ในการแก้ไข bit flip errors เราสามารถ
จัดการแต่ละ block แยกกัน แต่ละ block คือการเข้ารหัส qubit โดยใช้ three-bit repetition
code และโค้ดนั้นป้องกัน bit flip errors สมมติว่าก่อนอื่น X error เกิดขึ้นบน qubit ตัวใดตัวหนึ่ง
เช่น qubit กลางใน block กลาง ถ้าเราตรวจสอบแต่ละ block อย่างอิสระสำหรับ bit flip errors และ
แก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดที่พบ ข้อผิดพลาดนี้จะถูกแก้ไขและการเข้ารหัสต้นฉบับจะถูก
กู้คืน จริงๆ แล้วเราอาจมี X errors หลายตัวและยังคงแก้ไขได้ด้วยวิธีนี้ ตราบเท่าที่ข้อผิดพลาดอยู่ใน
blocks ที่แยกกัน ถ้าเรามี X errors สองหรือสามตัวใน block เดียว เราก็จะลำบาก แต่
ตราบเท่าที่มี X error ไม่เกินหนึ่งตัวต่อ block inner code จะจับมันได้และเราจะสามารถกู้คืนการเข้ารหัสต้นฉบับได้
ดังนั้นการแก้ไข bit flip errors เป็นเรื่องง่ายสำหรับโค้ดนี้ เราต้องพิจารณา phase flip errors ด้วย
หรืออีกนัยหนึ่ง Z errors คราวนี้ไม่ชัดเจนนักว่าเราควรทำอะไร เพราะ outer code คือตัวที่
แก้ไข phase flip errors แต่เราไม่สามารถตรวจจับและแก้ไขได้โดยตรงเพราะ inner code เป็นอุปสรรค
แต่เราจะเห็นวิธีการทำสิ่งนี้ในอีกสักครู่ เพื่อให้เข้าใจว่า X และ Z
errors ทำงานอย่างไรและมีผลอย่างไรภายใน quantum circuits มันช่วยในการสังเกตความสัมพันธ์ง่ายๆ บางอย่างระหว่างข้อผิดพลาดเหล่านี้และ C
NOT gates และนี่จะเป็นประโยชน์ในบทเรียนภายหลังด้วย ก่อนอื่นมาเริ่มกับ X errors
หรือ X gates และความสัมพันธ์กับ C NOT gates ถ้าเรา apply X gate กับ
target qubit ของ CNOT แล้ว apply CNOT มันก็เทียบเท่ากับการสลับลำดับและทำ CNOT
ก่อน ในทางกลับกันถ้าเรา apply X gate กับ control qubit ของ CNOT แล้ว apply CNOT เราไม่สามารถ
สลับลำดับได้ง่ายๆ แต่ต้อง apply X gate กับทั้งสอง qubit และคุณสามารถตรวจสอบความสัมพันธ์เหล่านี้ทั้งหมด
ด้วยตัวเองถ้าต้องการ โดยคิดถึงสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นกับ standard basis states เช่น สถานการณ์คล้ายกันสำหรับ Z
errors ยกเว้นว่า roles ของ control และ target qubits สลับกัน โดยเฉพาะถ้าเราทำ
Z gate บน control qubit ของ CNOT แล้วทำ CNOT มันมีผลเหมือนกับการทำ
Z gate หลัง CNOT แต่ถ้าเราทำ Z gate บน target qubit แทน นั่นก็
เทียบเท่ากับการทำ CNOT ก่อนแล้ว apply Z gate กับทั้งสอง qubit และสุดท้ายความสัมพันธ์ทั้งหมดเหล่านี้
มีความสมมาตรในแง่ที่เราสามารถสลับลำดับ gates ทั้งสองข้างของสมการได้เสมอ
ซึ่งเทียบเท่ากับการ invert หรือ conjugate transpose ของทั้งสองข้าง เนื่องจาก X, Z และ CNOT
gates ต่างก็เป็น inverse ของตัวเอง ตอนนี้ลองพิจารณา phase flip errors และเราจะตรวจจับและแก้ไข
ได้อย่างไรโดยใช้ 9 qubit Shore code นี่คือ circuit การเข้ารหัสของเรา และเราจะยังคิดเกี่ยวกับเก้า
qubit ที่ใช้ในการเข้ารหัสว่าถูกจัดกลุ่มเป็นสาม blocks มี qubit สามตัว สมมติว่า Z error เกิดขึ้นบน
qubit ตัวใดตัวหนึ่ง เช่น ตัวที่ระบุที่นี่ โดยใช้สิ่งที่เพิ่งสังเกตเกี่ยวกับ Z
gates และ CNOT gates มันเทียบเท่ากับ Z errors สองตัวก่อน CNOT หนึ่งตัวบน
control และหนึ่งตัวบน target qubit และข้อผิดพลาดเหล่านี้บังเอิญ commute กับ CNOT อื่นใน block ดังนั้นเรา
สามารถสลับลำดับได้ และนี่คือสิ่งที่เราได้รับ Z error ล่างไม่ทำอะไรเพราะมันกระทำบน zero
state และเราสามารถเลื่อนทุกอย่างและได้ diagram นี้ ดังนั้นสิ่งที่เราพบคือ Z error ที่อยู่ใดที่หนึ่งใน
block กลางนั้นเทียบเท่ากับ Z error ที่เกิดขึ้นบน qubit กลางก่อนขั้นตอนการเข้ารหัสที่สอง และ
คุณสามารถใช้เหตุผลเดียวกันสำหรับ Z error บน qubit ตัวใดก็ตาม phase flip บน qubit ตัวใดภายใน block
เทียบเท่ากับ phase flip บน qubit ที่สอดคล้องกันก่อนการเข้ารหัสภายใน และนั่นค่อนข้างตรงไปตรงมาและสัญชาตญาณถ้าคุณ
คิดถึงวิธีที่ Z errors ส่งผลต่อ three-bit repetition code ดังนั้นทางเลือกหนึ่งสำหรับการจัดการกับ Z
error คือการถอดรหัส inner code แล้วตรวจจับและแก้ไข Z errors โดยใช้ outer code ซึ่งเป็นเวอร์ชันที่ดัดแปลง
ของ 3-bit repetition code ที่สามารถแก้ไข Z error ได้ ดังนั้นสิ่งนั้นแก้ไข Z error ของเราและ
เราสามารถเข้ารหัสด้วย inner code อีกครั้งถ้าต้องการทำเช่นนั้น เราสามารถแก้ไข Z errors ได้
ในที่คือโดยไม่ต้องถอดรหัสและเข้ารหัสใหม่ และค่อนข้างตรงไปตรงมา แต่เพื่ออธิบายวิธีการ
เราจะต้องใช้พื้นที่อีกเล็กน้อย สมมติว่าเราถอดรหัส inner code
แล้วเราคำนวณ syndrome สำหรับ outer code โดยใช้วิธีเดียวกับก่อน ที่เราใช้แค่สาม qubit จาก outer code และ
จากนั้นเราเข้ารหัสอีกครั้ง เราสามารถลดความซับซ้อนของ CNOT เหล่านี้เล็กน้อยได้ และจริงๆ แล้ว
เราสามารถใช้ความสัมพันธ์ระหว่าง NOT gates และ CNOT gates ที่เพิ่งสังเกตเมื่อไม่นานมานี้เพื่อช่วย
และโดยการทำเช่นนั้นเราสามารถประหยัด CNOT ได้สี่ตัว และนี่คือ circuit ที่เราได้ ถ้า Z error เกิดขึ้นบน
qubit ตัวหนึ่ง สิ่งที่ syndrome บอกเราตอนนี้ไม่ใช่ว่า qubit ตัวใด ประสบ Z error แต่ว่า block ไหน Z error
เกิดขึ้น แต่นั่นก็โอเคเพราะเรารู้ว่าไม่ว่า qubit ตัวใดภายใน block จะประสบ Z error
ผลลัพธ์ก็เหมือนกันสำหรับทั้งสาม qubit ใน block นั้น ดังนั้นเราสามารถแก้ไข Z error ได้โดย apply Z gate กับ qubit ตัวใดก็ตาม
ใน block นั้น โดยวิธีนี้เป็นตัวอย่างของสิ่งที่เรียกว่า degeneracy ใน error
correcting code ที่เราไม่ระบุข้อผิดพลาดที่แน่นอนอย่างเฉพาะเจาะจง แต่เราสามารถแก้ไขได้อยู่ดี สุดท้ายสมมติว่าทั้ง
bit flip และ phase flip error เกิดขึ้น อาจเป็นบน qubit ตัวเดียวกัน ตัวอย่างเช่น สมมติว่า
bit flip และ phase flip error เกิดขึ้นบน qubit ตัวนี้ ปรากฏว่าข้อผิดพลาดเหล่านี้สามารถ
ตรวจจับและแก้ไขได้อย่างอิสระอย่างสมบูรณ์ และจริงๆ แล้วไม่สำคัญว่าเราแก้ไขแต่ละ block สำหรับ
bit flip ก่อนแล้วแก้ไข phase flips หรือทำในลำดับตรงกันข้าม เพื่อดูสิ่งนี้ มาสังเกตก่อน
ว่าลำดับของข้อผิดพลาดเหล่านี้ไม่สำคัญ ดังนั้นเราสามารถสลับมันได้ถ้าต้องการ เหตุผลไม่ใช่เพราะ
X และ Z commute เพราะพวกมันไม่ commute X คูณ Z เท่ากับ ลบ Z คูณ X แต่
ปัจจัย -1 ไม่มีผลในสถานการณ์นี้เพราะมันเป็น global phase เราสามารถย้าย Z error ได้เหมือน
ก่อน และในจุดนี้ชัดเจนว่าถ้าเราแก้ไขแต่ละ block สำหรับ X errors ก่อน แล้วแก้ไข
Z errors เราก็จะได้แก้ไขทั้งสองข้อผิดพลาด อีกทางหนึ่งถ้าด้วยเหตุผลบางอย่าง
เราตัดสินใจแก้ไข Z errors ก่อน เราก็ทำได้และ X error ไม่มีผลเลยในกระบวนการนั้น
สิ่งนั้นต้องเป็นจริงเพราะอย่างแรก X error commute กับทุก gate ใน circuit ที่คำนวณ
syndrome สำหรับ outer code และอย่างที่สอง ลำดับระหว่าง X error และ Z gate ที่เรา apply เพื่อแก้ไข
ไม่สำคัญเหมือนกับที่เราแย้งเมื่อ Z gate เป็นข้อผิดพลาด ดังนั้นสิ่งนั้นช่วยให้แก้ไข Z
error ได้ และเราสามารถแก้ไขแต่ละ block เพื่อกำจัด X error ได้ ดังนั้นสิ่งที่เราแย้งคือเรา
สามารถแก้ไข X error, Z error หรือทั้งสองบน qubit ตัวใดก็ตามโดยใช้โค้ดนี้
จริงๆ แล้วเราสามารถแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดได้มากกว่านั้น เช่น X errors หลายตัวตราบเท่าที่อยู่ใน blocks ที่แตกต่างกัน
หรือ Z errors หลายตัวตราบเท่าที่ block ไม่เกินหนึ่งได้รับจำนวนคี่ แต่สิ่งที่จะเกี่ยวข้องมากที่สุดต่อไปคือ
เราสามารถแก้ไข X error, Z error หรือทั้งสองบน qubit ตัวใดก็ตาม และในส่วนสุดท้ายของบทเรียน
เราจะเห็นว่าสิ่งนี้จริงๆ แล้วเพียงพอที่จะสรุปว่าโค้ดนี้สามารถแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดที่ arbitrary บน qubit ตัวใดก็ตาม
ก่อนที่เราจะไปยังส่วนสุดท้ายของบทเรียนที่เราจะพิจารณา quantum errors ที่ arbitrary เราจะพูดถึงสั้นๆ
เกี่ยวกับประสิทธิภาพของ 9 qubit Shore code เมื่อข้อผิดพลาดที่แสดงโดย Pauli matrices เกิดขึ้นแบบ random บน
qubit เพื่อให้ชัดเจนขึ้น ลองพิจารณา noise model ง่ายๆ ที่ข้อผิดพลาดเกิดขึ้นอย่างอิสระบน qubit
โดยแต่ละ qubit ประสบข้อผิดพลาดด้วยความน่าจะเป็น p และไม่มีความสัมพันธ์ระหว่างข้อผิดพลาดบน
qubit ต่างๆ กรณีที่แย่ที่สุดสำหรับ 9 qubit Shore code คือ Y error หรืออีกนัยหนึ่งทั้ง X error และ Z
error เกิดขึ้นบน qubit แต่ละตัวที่ได้รับผลกระทบ และเราจะสมมติกรณีที่แย่ที่สุดนี้เพียงเพื่อให้ได้ bound
ต่อประสิทธิภาพของโค้ด แต่คุณสามารถพิจารณาได้เช่นกัน ตัวอย่างเช่น Pauli errors สามตัวมีความน่าจะเป็น
เท่ากัน ตอนนี้สมมติว่า Q คือ qubit ในสถานะเฉพาะที่เราต้องการปกป้องจากข้อผิดพลาด และจินตนาการว่า
เรามีตัวเลือกในการใช้ 9 qubit Shore code เราควรใช้มันไหม คำตอบคือไม่จำเป็นต้อง
ใช่ เพราะถ้า noise มากเกินไปหรืออีกนัยหนึ่ง p ใหญ่เกินไป การใช้ Shore code อาจทำให้สิ่งต่างๆ
แย่ลง เหมือนกับที่เรามีกับ repetition code เมื่อ p มากกว่า 1/2 แต่ถ้า p เล็กพอ
คำตอบคือใช่ เราควรใช้โค้ด ดังนั้นมาดูว่าทำไมสิ่งนี้ถึงเป็นเช่นนั้น และ p ที่ใหญ่เกินไปหรือเล็กพอหมายความว่าอะไร
สำหรับโค้ดนี้ Shore code สามารถแก้ไข Pauli error ใดๆ บน qubit เดียว และในกรณีที่แย่ที่สุด
ที่ Pauli errors เป็น Y errors หมายความว่าโค้ดปกป้อง Q ได้สำเร็จด้วยความน่าจะเป็นตามนิพจน์ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ
โดยเฉพาะโค้ดทำงานเมื่อไม่มีข้อผิดพลาด ซึ่งเกิดขึ้น
ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 1 ลบ p กำลัง 9 เพราะมีเก้า qubit ที่แต่ละตัวต้องไม่ได้รับผลกระทบ และมันทำงานเมื่อมี
ข้อผิดพลาดเดียวพอดี และเนื่องจากมีเก้า qubit ต่างกันที่อาจได้รับผลกระทบ สิ่งนี้เกิดขึ้นด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 9 คูณ P คูณ (1 - p) กำลัง 8
ในทางกลับกัน ถ้าเราไม่ใช้โค้ด qubit เดียวของเราจะไม่ได้รับผลกระทบจากข้อผิดพลาดด้วยความน่าจะเป็น
หนึ่งลบ P ดังนั้นโค้ดช่วยได้ก็ต่อเมื่อความน่าจะเป็นแรกมีค่ามากกว่าความน่าจะเป็นที่สอง
เพราะนิพจน์เหล่านี้แทนความน่าจะเป็นของความสำเร็จในทั้งสองกรณี เมื่อเราใช้โค้ดและเมื่อ
เราไม่ใช้ นี่คือกราฟของฟังก์ชันทั้งสองสำหรับค่า p ที่เล็ก และเราพบว่า break even point อยู่ที่
ประมาณ 3 และ 3/4 เปอร์เซ็นต์ ดังนั้นถ้า p เล็กกว่าค่านี้โค้ด
ก็ช่วยได้ ที่ break even point ความน่าจะเป็นเท่ากัน ดังนั้นเราแค่เสียเวลาพร้อมกับ 8 qubit ถ้า
เราใช้โค้ด แต่นอกจากนั้นก็ไม่เป็นไร และเกินจุดนั้นเราไม่ควรใช้โค้ดนี้เลย
เพราะมันเพิ่มโอกาสข้อผิดพลาดบน qubit ที่เข้ารหัสซึ่งเราเรียกว่า
logical qubit ในบริบทนี้ และสิ่งนั้นเกิดขึ้นเพียงเพราะโอกาสที่จะมีข้อผิดพลาดสองตัวหรือมากกว่าบนเก้า qubit
มากกว่าโอกาสที่จะมีข้อผิดพลาดหนึ่งตัวบน qubit เดียวสำหรับค่า p ในช่วงนี้ 3 และ 3/4 เปอร์เซ็นต์อาจดูไม่ดีนัก
โดยเฉพาะเมื่อเทียบกับ 50% ซึ่งเป็น break even point ที่คล้ายกันสำหรับ three-bit repetition code สำหรับ
ข้อมูลแบบคลาสสิก แต่การปกป้องข้อมูลควอนตัมนั้นยากกว่า และยิ่งไปกว่านั้น แม้ว่า
โค้ดนี้แสดงถึงการค้นพบที่ยอดเยี่ยมในฐานะ quantum error correcting code ตัวแรก และมีประโยชน์มากสำหรับวัตถุประสงค์ทางการศึกษา ความจริง
ก็คือมันไม่ใช่โค้ดที่ดีมากในทางปฏิบัติ จนถึงตอนนี้เราพิจารณา X errors
และ Z errors ในบริบทของ 9 qubit Shore code ตอนนี้ลองพิจารณาข้อผิดพลาดที่ arbitrary
เริ่มต้นด้วย unitary errors ก่อน ตัวอย่างเช่น ข้อผิดพลาดดังกล่าวอาจสอดคล้องกับการหมุนเล็กน้อย
ของ Bloch sphere ซึ่งอาจแสดงถึงข้อผิดพลาดที่เกิดจาก gate ที่ไม่สมบูรณ์แบบ ตัวอย่างเช่น
หรืออาจเป็น unitary operation ใดๆ บน qubit และไม่จำเป็นต้องใกล้เคียงกับ identity
operation ดูเหมือนว่าการแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดเหล่านี้จะยาก มีข้อผิดพลาดที่เป็นไปได้จำนวนอนันต์เช่นนี้
และเป็นไปไม่ได้ที่เราจะระบุได้ว่าข้อผิดพลาดนั้นคืออะไรกันแน่แล้วยกเลิกมัน แต่เรา
ไม่จำเป็นต้องทำอะไรต่างจากที่พูดถึงไปแล้ว ตราบเท่าที่เราสามารถแก้ไข bit flip, phase flip หรือทั้งสองได้ เราก็จะ
สำเร็จในการแก้ไข unitary error เดี่ยวที่ arbitrary บน qubit และฉันจะอธิบายตอนนี้ว่าทำไม
ก่อนอื่น เหมือนกับ matrix 2x2 ทั้งหมด เราสามารถแสดง unitary matrix ที่ arbitrary
ซึ่งแทนข้อผิดพลาดบน qubit เดียวได้เป็น linear combination ของ Pauli matrices สี่ตัวรวมถึง identity
matrix และโดยวิธีอย่างที่คุณอาจสังเกตเห็น ฉันใช้ตัวพิมพ์ใหญ่ X, Y และ Z เพื่อระบุ Pauli matrices ที่ไม่ใช่ identity
และฉันจะทำต่อไปตลอดซีรีส์นี้ นั่นเป็นแบบแผนในการแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดควอนตัม และยัง
ทำให้อ่านง่ายขึ้นในบริบทนี้ นอกจากนี้จะสะดวกในการใช้ subscript เพื่อระบุว่า
Cubit unitary operation กระทำบน qubit ตัวไหน ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเราใช้การนับ Qiskit
convention เริ่มจาก qubit ศูนย์ทางขวา เราก็จะมีนิพจน์ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอสำหรับ
unitary operations ต่างๆ บน qubit เดียว โดยในแต่ละกรณีเรา tensor unitary matrix กับ identity matrix
บน qubit ตัวอื่นทุกตัว ดังนั้นโดยเฉพาะเราสามารถแสดง UK ซึ่งหมายถึง U ที่กระทำบน qubit K ได้เป็น
linear combination เดิม ยกเว้น Pauli matrix แต่ละตัวถูก apply กับ qubit K เราไม่จำเป็นต้องใส่
subscript สำหรับ identity โดยวิธี ความเข้าใจที่นี่คือนี่คือ identity บน
qubit ทั้งหมด ตอนนี้สมมติว่า Sai คือการเข้ารหัส 9 qubit ของ qubit state ถ้าข้อผิดพลาด U เกิดขึ้นกับ
qubit k เราได้ UK คูณ S ซึ่งเราสามารถแสดงเป็น linear combination ของ Pauli operations ที่กระทำบน S ซึ่งแน่นอน
คือ S ในกรณีของ identity ในจุดนี้จะเป็นประโยชน์ในการสังเกตว่า Pauli Y
matrix เท่ากับ i คูณ X คูณ Z ดังนั้นเราสามารถแทนค่านั้นใน
นิพจน์ของเรา ดังนั้นข้อผิดพลาดนี้เกิดขึ้นแล้ว และตอนนี้สมมติว่าเราพยายามแก้ไขมันโดยใช้ขั้นตอนเดียวกัน
เหมือนก่อน ขั้นตอนแรกคือคำนวณ syndrome ซึ่งในกรณีของ Shore code มีความยาว 8 bit สองบิตสำหรับแต่ละครั้ง
ที่เราใช้ inner code พร้อมกับสองบิตเพิ่มเติมสำหรับ outer code แต่จริงๆ ไม่สำคัญเราแค่คิดว่ามันเป็น
string ที่มีความยาวคงที่ นี่คือการอธิบายสถานะที่เราได้ก่อนการวัด syndrome ที่
syndrome แต่ละตัวคือ 8 bit ที่เราได้จาก Pauli error ที่สอดคล้องกัน สังเกตในจุดนี้ว่าสอง
ระบบมีความสัมพันธ์กันโดยทั่วไป และนี่คือกุญแจสำคัญในการทำให้ทุกอย่างทำงาน โดยการวัด syndrome สิ่งที่
เราจะทำอย่างมีประสิทธิผลคือ collapse สถานะเป็นสถานะที่ Pauli operations ตัวใดตัวหนึ่งจากสี่ตัวถูก apply กับ
Ki qubit ของ Sai และเราจะรู้จาก syndrome ว่า Pauli operation ใด ดังนั้นเราสามารถแก้ไขมันถ้า
จำเป็น โดยเฉพาะถ้าเราวัด syndrome และทำการแก้ไขที่เหมาะสม เราก็ได้สถานะของ
รูปแบบที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ ซึ่งที่สำคัญมากคือ product state เรามีการเข้ารหัสต้นฉบับที่ไม่เสียหายเป็น
tensor factor ด้านขวา ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งสำคัญที่สุดที่นี่ และทางซ้ายเรามี density matrix s ที่
อธิบาย error syndrome แบบ random แต่ไม่มีความสัมพันธ์กับระบบที่เราสนใจซึ่งคือ
ด้านขวา เพราะข้อผิดพลาดได้รับการแก้ไขแล้ว ณ จุดนี้เราสามารถทิ้ง syndrome qubits หรือ reset ได้ใน
กรณีที่ต้องการใช้งานใหม่ และนั่นสำคัญมากเพราะนี่คือวิธีที่ความสุ่มหรือ entropy
ที่เกิดจากข้อผิดพลาดถูกกำจัดออกจากระบบ และนั่นคือวิธีที่ discretization of errors ทำงาน อย่างน้อยสำหรับ unitary
errors โดยพื้นฐานแล้วโดยการวัด syndrome เราจะ project ข้อผิดพลาดไปยังข้อผิดพลาดที่อธิบายโดย
Pauli matrix มองดูเผินๆ อาจดูดีเกินไปที่เราสามารถแก้ไข unitary errors ที่ arbitrary ได้
เช่นนี้ แม้แต่ข้อผิดพลาดที่เล็กน้อยและแทบจะสังเกตไม่เห็นด้วยตัวเอง แต่สิ่งสำคัญที่ต้องตระหนักที่นี่
คือนี่คือ unitary error บน qubit เดียว และโดยการออกแบบของโค้ด การดำเนินการ qubit เดียวไม่สามารถเปลี่ยนแปลง
สถานะของ logical qubit ที่กำลังเข้ารหัสได้ สิ่งที่มันทำได้คือย้ายสถานะออกจากพื้นที่ของ valid
encodings แต่การแก้ไขจะนำมันกลับมาที่เดิม สุดท้ายมาพิจารณาสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้น
เมื่อเกิดข้อผิดพลาดที่ arbitrary ซึ่งไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็น unitary การตั้งค่าเหมือนกับก่อน
เราเข้ารหัส qubit หนึ่งเป็น 9 โดยใช้ Shore code และข้อผิดพลาดที่ arbitrary แสดงโดย qubit channel
เกิดขึ้นบน qubit ตัวหนึ่ง อย่างที่เราจะเห็น ทุกอย่างจะออกมาในลักษณะเดียวกันโดยประมาณ
กับ unitary errors และก้าวแรกในการยืนยันสิ่งนี้คือพิจารณา Kraus representation ของข้อผิดพลาดของเรา
สิ่งที่เราทำได้ตอนนี้คือทำตามเหตุผลเดียวกันกับ unitary errors ยกเว้น apply มัน
กับ Kraus matrices แทนที่จะเป็น unitary matrix เดียวที่แสดงข้อผิดพลาด
โดยเฉพาะ Kraus matrix แต่ละตัวสามารถแสดงเป็น linear combination ของ Pauli matrices และสิ่งนี้ช่วยให้เรา
แสดงการกระทำของข้อผิดพลาดนี้ phi บน qubit K ที่มันเกิดขึ้นในรูปแบบที่แสดงที่นี่บน
หน้าจอ สิ่งที่เราทำอยู่จริงๆ คือขยาย Kraus matrices เป็น linear combinations ของ Pauli
matrices ถ้าเราคำนวณและวัด error syndrome และแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดที่เปิดเผย เราจะได้
สถานะที่คล้ายกับที่เราได้ในกรณีของ unitary error ฉันจะไม่ผ่านรายละเอียด มันทั้งหมดค่อนข้างคล้ายกับ unitary
case และยังยุ่งเล็กน้อยกว่าในการเขียน แต่ในแง่แนวคิดค่อนข้าง
ตรงไปตรงมา ควรกล่าวว่าสิ่งนี้ generalize ไปยัง quantum error correcting codes อื่นๆ รวมถึงโค้ดที่สามารถแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดบน qubit หลายตัวได้
ในกรณีดังกล่าว ข้อผิดพลาดบน qubit หลายตัวสามารถแสดงเป็น linear combinations ของ tensor products ของ Pauli
matrices และ syndrome ต่างๆ ที่สอดคล้องกันจะอธิบายการแก้ไขที่ทำบน qubit หลายตัวแทนที่จะเป็นแค่หนึ่ง
qubit แต่แนวคิดพื้นฐานก็เหมือนกันทุกประการ อีกครั้งโดยการวัด syndrome
เราจะ project หรือ collapse ข้อผิดพลาดไปยังชุดของความเป็นไปได้ที่ไม่ต่อเนื่องซึ่งแสดงโดย tensor
products ของ Pauli matrices และโดยการแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดเหล่านั้นซึ่งหมายถึง Pauli errors เราสามารถกู้คืน
สถานะที่เข้ารหัสต้นฉบับได้ ในขณะที่ความสุ่มใดๆ ที่เกิดขึ้นในกระบวนการจะถูกย้ายไปยัง syndrome qubits ที่เราสามารถ
ทิ้งหรือ reset ได้ ซึ่งสำคัญมากเพราะนั่นคือวิธีที่ entropy ที่เกิดจากข้อผิดพลาดและการวัด syndrome ถูก
กำจัดออกจากระบบ และนั่นคือจุดสิ้นสุดของบทเรียนที่เราได้ทำความรู้จักกับ
quantum error correction ครั้งแรก รวมถึง 9 qubit Shore code และ discretization of errors หวังว่าคุณจะมาร่วมกับฉันใน
บทเรียนถัดไปที่เราจะพูดถึง stabilizer formalism ซึ่งให้เครื่องมือที่ทรงพลังสำหรับการอธิบายและ
วิเคราะห์ class ของ quantum error correcting codes ที่ใหญ่และน่าสนใจ รวมถึงโค้ดที่เป็นผู้สมัครที่มีแนวโน้มสำหรับ
คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมจริง ลาก่อนจนกว่าจะพบกันใหม่